stop stop stop arrêtez de garder vos
vieux téléphone dans les placards déjà
ils ont de la valeur donc vous pouvez
les envoyer à un reconditionneur qui va
pouvoir regarder comment il est qui a
pour pouvoir le réparer qu'il va pouvoir
lui mettre une note et le remettre sur
le marché elle revend donc ça c'est bien
déjà pour votre portefeuille parce
qu'ils vont venir vous payez ils vont
venir vous le racheter c'est bon pour la
planète laisse-moi ils vont pouvoir
continuer à vivre la seconde main c'est
extrêmement important et puis si votre
smartphone il est mort il est mort et
bien il va venir le recycler ça c'est
vachement cool parce que vous dans votre
placard votre smartphone tout seul il va
pas se reconditionner il va pas se
recycler et il servira à rien donc
regardez dans votre placard même lorsque
vous changez de téléphone est-ce que
vous n'avez pas un smartphone qui a de
la valeur qui est encore vivant qui
pourrait servir c'est un geste important
pour votre portefeuille pour la planète
pour l'économie circulaire bref c'est
bien c'est important alors vous faites
quoi vous ouvrez les placards vous
regardez c'est chouette hein c'est bien
allez on y va